maybe you say in the name of jesus
i rebuke you state maybe you should say
that and then he was like all right
he goes in the name of jesus i rebuke
you say
you [ __ ] started freaking the [ __ ]
out
like screaming screaming and running
into the walls and
[ __ ] punching himself in the face and
scratching his
face off and so i grabbed his [ __ ]
arms right in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast we have ed park here
once again and i am here nice and toasty
back from the beautiful
island of hawaii nice and golden is fun
nice
you know what i you know what i found
out i have what's up i have a sun
allergy
what i have a [ __ ] sun allergy dude
that sounds like it sucks i mean you're
not albino so check it out
so people get sun allergies when they
don't have a lot of exposure to uv rays
on a consistent basis
so the uv rays in hawaii like
specifically a lot of people experience
this when they go to tropical islands or
places closer to the equator or whatever
because the uv rays are a lot stronger
yeah you know
la is covered in pollution so you know i
do get sun but it's different
yeah over there zero pollution
completely just the sun beating down on
you damn you're the equator
yeah so it's it's different right so
when i when i go out there i used to
think that it was a heat rash and so
essentially what a heat rash is a diaper
rash
so you get that from i used to get it a
lot when um
in my in my swim trunks area or whatever
and i assume that that was a
a heat rash that was getting because of
the moisture and the friction from the
clothes right
i have a [ __ ] sun allergy and so
i found this out because uh tiffany and
casey they also went to hawaii with me
yeah and when we went together she was
like oh i have a sun allergy and i
looked at her
the stuff that she has she'll show me
photos i'm like hold on that's what i
have i had the same thing
and i googled what sun allergies look
like and i'm like it's the same [ __ ]
that i have
whoa and so everywhere that was exposed
to sun that specifically i didn't use
a gratuitous amount of sunscreen that
didn't typically get sun
i would break out in rashes and hives so
you could actually see remnants of it
here this this was a height
yeah yeah it's like a remaining bruise
exactly so this was a hive
mosquito these were hives and so my skin
right now actually kind of feels
rough because the uh the inflammation
has died down
and the uh the places that were hived up
that was scratching has now dried up
so the only thing that was like the sand
or some [ __ ] salt water
yeah i thought it was like a heat rash
because it was in my short area but it's
not from that it's like when my
my pants rides up and the sun's beating
down on and it gets burned a little bit
it causes a [ __ ] uh allergic reaction
to the sun the uv rays
wow and so the only way that you get rid
of uh
of a of a [ __ ] sun allergy is through
constant exposure of the [ __ ] sun
you just have to keep going outside so i
just had to [ __ ] deal with it
so i'm out there and at night i'm
scratching myself like a [ __ ]
crackhead
and then it took i was there for eight
days on the seventh day it finally
started getting better
oh man well did you enjoy that last day
the eighth day was great
yeah it was the day i was on a plane
right
but you had a lot to eat too right
exactly i ate a lot out there i gained
[ __ ]
exactly 10 pounds from eating food i
mean that's expected
but then you knew it was gonna happen
but you were shocked
i was shocked by the amount of weight i
was gonna
gain like five pounds four pounds the
ten pounds shocked me the most
damn but i understand because i was
eating like i just got out of like
[ __ ] um
like prison well for me like uh because
i'm like
hardcore keto like crazy man keto when i
have my cheat days
it is a crazy fluctuation oh because my
body's like
sugar and it just stores it takes all
that fat and
shoots it right back into my hips as a
skinny man i still get stretch marks on
my love handles oh really
because that's where my body wants to
store the fat that's [ __ ] funny so
one
so like dude uh stevie um
took me or my brother-in-law yeah he
took me to [ __ ] m grill
right and they have that grilled
pineapple
yeah and yeah i haven't had fruit in a
long [ __ ] i'm gonna say a year bro
damn you know like that's how crazy
manketo i am
so they give me this roasted pineapple
and when i bit into it i
literally got overwhelmed and i started
crying
like i've abstained from that kind of
sugar for so long like that's [ __ ]
it was euphoric i actually felt the high
of sugar
really yes tingled in my fingers and in
my toes
my calves tingled my ass tingled i know
what that feels like somewhat because
like what
i've been back from hawaii about two
days right yeah uh
first day i didn't eat i didn't really
have any processed carbs
just because i know like i've had it for
eight days straight in an
absorbent amount like fried rice uh
[ __ ]
cake ube pancakes yeah uh desserts
drinks a lot of alcohol i was doing i
was living it up
yeah and so the second day i had a scent
food shoe where
were we adding it was a fast food thing
i eat all fast food
i've been into a piece of bread and i
started smiling
just for one [ __ ] day without
processed carbs i was like oh
wow which is kind of nuts like it's
weird when you
i i think the stain just a little bit
right a lot of people don't know this
too
when you like i think your body is so
advanced
that we can the body can normalize
discomfort and pain
very well right where we don't know what
our body is going through until we are
we go without it right right so like
with the whole sugar thing like you
don't know how much your body craves
these things or how much you feel like
you need it yeah
right i didn't realize that you know
like i said when we were talking about
diarrhea
i was like oh it's not every day
is always funny bro yeah it's the korean
dance the korean spicy right yeah salsa
and that's salsa yeah
i'm like oh diary it's not everything i
had no clue
because i was normalizing these things
you know right right and then when i
find out something small too it's like
like today too i've been eating no
processed carbs except for maybe i
had like some like japanese iodine
crackers right right
but other than that uh if i do have
carbs just like from fruits
yeah with a lot of high dietary fiber
and then just clean protein like tilapia
salmon fish
i like it and it tastes good but i'm
like hungry
all the time like i'm craving these
things right it's the sugar calling
yeah right like i had this little jar of
m m's and it's just like
did you just say my name yeah
[Laughter]
it's like the sound of a little [ __ ]
korean k-pop star
my name is candy
[Laughter]
my name is strumpet
but yeah i uh i definitely understood
like going through these withdrawals but
it was cool
crazy because when i was in hawaii and i
was eating all that food i knew how bad
it was making me feel and i just kept
eating it
i just kept eating it i was like this is
making me feel terrible
but what's for dinner but i just
kept chowing down and actually if you
want to do keto in hawaii it's pretty
easy
you know um well i guess like some of
this is so much
pork there's so much pork like you could
just eat kahlua pork
uh cabbage out there you could have uh
everything's deep fried yeah you could
have [ __ ] lau lau yeah a bunch of
[ __ ] is deep-fried
[ __ ] spam uh just oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i
gotta go
it's been like it's literally been
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's been 10 years since i've
been hawaii
were you doing hawaii the last time just
vacation uh i was a missionary
you know how it is how are you gonna
evangelize a bunch of hawaiians that's
where the face was man
like it was like i'd make a stop there
before i went to japan
once um and that was that was where the
headquarters was for all the
missions training like theology training
i hear japan is not a place that they
send first missionaries like that's the
hardest place to go it's the hardest
why is that because they think you're
[ __ ] if you're a christian
they literally think you're really they
think you're
something's wrong like yeah and so they
feel like you're
like mentally challenged yeah you're a
[ __ ] outcast of society if you're
christian
okay think about it dude japan for all
we know is a free country right
you can do whatever you want nine
percent christian
oh wow yeah it's just a
cultural thing like so they had that 200
year isolation right
and the first ones were like the dutch
and spanish
catholic like missionaries and [ __ ] and
whenever they came they just [ __ ]
tortured and murdered them
no that they brought back crucifixion
they crucified these priests dude yeah
they tortured them
and culturally is just like it's just so
antithetical to japanese philosophy that
they saw it as a threat
to japanese way of life like 200 years
ago or so
and so the outcome of that even though
they went relaxed
it was just generally amongst their
culture it's like
yeah they're a little uh yeah that's why
crazy yeah it'd be crazy to be christian
out there so
it's a lot of like learning the culture
and like um
proving yourself showing yourself and
like being there for them
like literally like real relationships
with these people
see because i never understood that
because i had a roommate in college
named daniel daniel wu
yeah and he would do a lot of missionary
work yeah and he goes like yeah so
we have to go to easier places first
before we go to like some of the more
hardcore places where we're missionaries
i went to iraq and haiti first i went to
japan
yeah he's right he's not kidding well
that's what i'm saying i was like where
are you going he goes
i gotta go to a mongolian village
[Laughter]
hold on you said it was easy he goes
yeah they say like japan's really hard
but he never explained to me why i don't
think he knew either yeah but when he
went to mongolia this fool said like he
threw up every meal
because they because he loved animals or
some [ __ ] oh and therefore had to eat
horse
yeah they eat oh yeah for sure yeah yeah
he had to eat horsey drink
of course wine which horse wine is just
fermented [ __ ] milk
it's fermented [ __ ] horse milk
[Laughter]
that's exactly what he was eating and he
was telling me that japan is a place
that you don't go until you get a couple
of missions under your belt first
yeah that's for sure and like i was
there with like other missionary
students in their tokyo base
and [ __ ] and um so i was there for the
tsunami
and like i said at that time like they
don't like christians already
guess who all the christians are in
japan they're all korean
oh for real oh my god of course they are
right
because japan like think about it if if
we like going to mexico for mission
trips where
where do koreans like going to mission
trips uh japan or china
of course or the philippines like but
big time they go to japan
for the missions and all that um but
when the earthquake hit
and fukushima melted down all them
koreans
left oh for real they bounced
dude that is the worst thing that you
could do yeah
and so like all the mish all the pastors
all the christians like that are cr
they [ __ ] bounce after the earthquake
because they have a safe space in korea
because of the nuclear threat or
whatever yeah and then
um you know all the work was undone
yeah and then so i show up and i'm
korean american you know and you know
how it is korean japanese beef
yeah yeah yeah um and yeah it i was
there under people's homes cleaning up
muck and [ __ ] just smell i smell dead
bodies
that's crazy real [ __ ] i seen entire
valleys like if you can imagine like
you're in the hollywood hills and you
look down you see la is a valley right
yeah imagine it being [ __ ] wiped out
because
a [ __ ] like tsunami just it just took
everything out i was looking over this
valley it was flat
dude that when when though that tsunami
happened there was like clips
of cars trying to outrun the tsunami
yeah you know a car is going like 80 90
100 miles an hour
and they can't beat it i'm like how
[ __ ] fast is that wave dude
and you just see somebody just getting
taken out so not only that like
imagine this too like as i would we i
went down to
ground zero and i'm looking at just
destroy destruction
[ __ ] everything's gone right and
flattened out or just
crazy and so it's this valley and then
there's a hill straight up
it just goes up and there's a high
school at the
base of that this hill and apparently
that was
where the evacuation site is because the
tsunami comes so people go
on the top floor yeah right but the
tsunami brought in
all these oil tankers and these ships
containers and they cracked open and
they were
on fire so i'm looking at this high
school it's burnt out right i was like i
thought a tsunami came here
everything looks burnt yeah like a fire
came through
a wall of fire burning fire on top of
the tsunami so people thought they were
safe when they were on top of
their like hundreds of people on top of
this high school then a while a [ __ ]
fire came
on top of the water and they burned it
there
that's [ __ ] crazy dude [ __ ] crazy
that's the [ __ ] i saw out there you know
and so me being their ground zero
living talking about people telling
people i'm korean you know and an
american too and i don't even speak
japanese
this japanese lady that i was with like
she's like can i give you a hug i'm like
okay right and we hugged her she was
like
that's the first time i've hugged
somebody
since i was a baby oh like what
wow what the hell she's like i'm so
japanese
my husband didn't hug me i don't
remember last my parents hugged me
the last time i hugged my son when when
he was an
adolescent you know that's crazy this is
like this is japanese
you know she's like i gave birth to my
kid by him he came in his hand and he
stuck it inside me
like what the [ __ ] so she was just
saying she's like she said
i'm so japanese but none of us are
japanese right she's like
trying not to be japanese around us and
gave us hugs wow that's
crazy you know how old was she yo she
was in her 70s or 80s when the tsunami
hit
hello my friends before we continue you
sexy brain farts let's talk about our
lovely sponsor magic spoon
i love cereal but i do not love the fact
that it's probably one of the worst
breakfast foods you can have
ever you're sad because i bet you're
thinking there isn't a single cereal
product on the market that has zero
grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving
well say less you dummy there's magic
spoon thank me later because you get to
go back to being a kid and eating bomb
ass cereal without the sugar crash and
guilt
i'm talking about cocoa farooty frosted
and peanut butter flavored nutritious
cereal
so go to magicspoon.com brain to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code brain
at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so
confident in their product is back with
a 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com brain and use the code
brain
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
there is this one lady old japanese lady
who [ __ ] held
to her kitchen sink you know and waited
till someone saved her
this lady has luckily has a second floor
not many japanese floors
homes do she was stuck up there for two
weeks waiting for the water to drain
she survived off who knows what what you
know what i'm saying
[ __ ] like i was just grounded bro ground
zero it was
[ __ ] crazy how long ago was this this
was
2011 right when the tsunami yeah 2011.
the earthquake hit the tsunami hit and
me and my christian self felt this
calling like
i better go yeah that's how i went
did you see any dead bodies no
but i definitely smelled them there's no
doubt the
worst i smelled the
uh like a dog carcass and i threw up
yeah
it's like if you have never smelt a
living being's carcass rotting it is
it there is no other smell that is like
it it's very distinct
i i was i was there like a month
so probably two weeks after the water
subsided it was a lot of
terrible it those bad smells
it it really affects like just the
thought of the smell
yeah yeah it [ __ ] me up inside because
like when i came back home
too people would be like yo how was
japan like i went on a
[ __ ] like vacation i was like it was
terrible
yeah man i was like i went to a [ __ ]
natural disaster site dude
yeah yo did you see did you beat any
hookers did she go to shibuya
[Laughter]
shinjuku like when you smell it's
something something crazy to the point
where i feel
that it's genetically like in our dna
that when we smell that
smell it triggers something really bad
we revolted that this is bad this is not
right
it's like because i so i was uh walking
around in long beach and i was uh
visiting
my so my best friend gabba was here and
then we were visiting his
sister see how she's doing she's okay
out there
and then well first of all this whole
god [ __ ] no [ __ ] smell at all
because he smelled that he was fine
i smelt that and then i felt this
electricity surged through my
like your fire my hair stood up right
and then i started
gagging i was like what the [ __ ] is that
and i looked into a bush and there was
like a dead pit bull like rotting
and that was the smell of a rotting
carcass and it's crazy
how my body reacted it was so it was
such a revolting thing to smell
like my body just exploded like every
sense in my body my
pores all opened up like what the [ __ ]
is get the [ __ ] out of here but there's
no other smell like i could ever equate
it to
except dead body smell like i i don't
even know how to describe it yeah
there's nothing in this world that
smells like that
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] bad that's
[ __ ] crazy
i didn't know you went there after the
the the the tsunami that's crazy yeah it
was uh
it was one of those things man when i
was a crazy man like yeah i'm saving all
my crazy for my diet you know
yeah but my crazy man [ __ ] was yeah
going to iraq going to haiti after
the earthquake and um i went there twice
second time i went like months later the
same year it was still a [ __ ] mess
i believe to this day it was just it was
in the middle of the cholera outbreak
it was [ __ ] wild like that's how it
is like you know when uh during the
whole kanye west bush hates black people
yes
like new orleans right yeah you go out
there so when i was out in new orleans
and i was talking to the uber driver i
was like yo like new orleans kind of
came back from the disaster they're like
oh sweetie that's not
that you're only seeing the part that
the city chose to rebuild yeah there's
like everywhere else here people's house
are still destroyed it's been five six
years
like they still the government still
hasn't helped like our house homes are
destroyed like i'm working out in the
city right now but
i'll take if i take you out you know 20
miles out i'll show you how how bad it
is still
and this is this is supposed to be one
of the most prosperous countries
in the world right we're supposed to be
the rich wealthy country
and our government still hasn't fixed
those homes out in new orleans that was
hit by a [ __ ] disaster
i mean look at flint too how long have
they had terrible bad pipes they still
have bad water
yeah dude which doesn't make any sense
at all i don't get it yeah i still don't
get it there's just a lot of forgotten
people like you know i i i sought in
myself to like about
because i had to check myself as to me
going out to these other nations
um i i benefited
so much from that personally in my
personal growth
and whatever um but at the same time i'm
like
yeah people here suffer people here
suffer and i had to really question like
how
i affect my community yeah you know and
how much i care from there too there's a
lot of
just it was a big epic journey i think a
lot of growth
i don't think i could have ever done the
missionary work that you did i didn't
have the balls to do [ __ ] like that
because i was crazy bro i was literally
being like this is what the bible says
it's like i in my head i'm reading it
like
if god is jesus is real right yeah and
he was here in this moment
with you and oh my god he revealed
himself right
and oh my god a cloud is taking up to
heaven right
he's like bye i gotta go right and jesus
is leaving he's ascending
and they're and you're like jesus wait
before you go what's the last thing you
want to tell us
what's he say go into the world and make
disciples
so i'm like okay what does that mean
these personal relationships
deep discipleship like accountability
and your integrity all these things like
that go with it
you know yeah and then to go into the
world
you know go out there leave your home
you know and
not only that sell your stuff baba i i
went deep end
you know what's crazy there was actually
i remember a moment where somebody
almost
ruined my christianity based on
something that they told me that was
supposed to uplift me
i was i was doing i was out going into
those uh what do you call not mission
trips but you know when you go out
um with a group of the church and you go
and run out of cabin and you do all
praise and worship
oh yeah like a retreat retreat so we
went on a retreat right and
uh there's a dude named hans i i look up
the hans a lot i heard i heard
uh it's a korean guy yeah he's a krieger
with the [ __ ] germany
right dude is super dope right i think
he's i think he's still christian i
don't know but
uh people this guy was this dude was
telling the story
about how he was possessed by a demon
right okay
and he was talking about this like it
happened to him the night before
while we were sleeping and he woke up in
a fervor screaming
and we're like what happened and the
next day he was describing this moment
he goes i had a dream that when i was in
the cabin there was two demons
that came down and i was staring at them
telling them to leave me alone
one of them came down grabbed my chest
and ripped
the spirit out of my body and they were
dragging me to hell
okay and these two demons were dragging
me out screaming
asking god to help me and i couldn't do
anything i just see my lifeless body
laying in bed
as i'm sinking down into the floor and
i'm going into the depths of hell
yeah and then he just kept saying the
lord's prayer over and over and over
until he snapped at him and he came back
and he was back into his body and he
woke up
right and i'm young he's telling this
story i'm
scared shitless i'm in the same [ __ ]
cabin with this guy right
right and so this dude hans tries to
comfort me by saying this phrase he goes
listen satan only attacks those
who have really strong faith
and i told him to be a sinner that's why
i said i was like
i am not christian
[Laughter]
i heard that one too i was like why
would you tell me that
now i'm going to go jack off and do
crazy things
because if he's going i'm i was like
trying to find a way to teeter between
being a sinner and
believing in god you know so it's like
i'm not strong enough for satan will
attack
like what the [ __ ] why would you say
that to me dude yeah i mean like those
things
though like i um in those missions
training they
teach you on it's called spiritual
warfare week
right and they have all kinds of stories
of demonic
like uh oppression yeah right or
even possession and
the the way they tell these stories get
pretty wild like i told you those smith
wigglesworth stories
you know where you know
he punched a guy in the stomach and his
tumor flew out his back he kicked the
[ __ ] dead baby and he came back to
life
you know there's these crazy stories
they believe in but
yeah there was even a time when i was
you youth leader
um at our church retreat right and
uh you know it's the last night and we
all have lamian and we play like mafia
and stuff right
and then all church retreats and then
this kid
comes back from his run and he's just
pale and he's scared he's like edward
teacher
can you pray for me can you pray for me
i'm like what's going on and he's like
they're demons chasing me i see a demon
there's a demon right there like in the
trees he's staring at us can we go
inside
like what the [ __ ] i'm all right and
this kid's like 17 years old
i i take him into the room and he's just
sweating inhale he's like can you close
those blinds there's a team
staring at us right now he's right there
he's staring at us
all right and i don't know what the [ __ ]
to do right
i'm just just yeah i tell him like
well then you know let's pray you know
hold his hands
you know you know in the power of jesus
name you know
satan we going to ask you to go away and
i'm just like well i hope you feel
better you know i yeah i have no idea
what the [ __ ] to do right
and um it's late at night now and he's a
senior and we have this rule where we
give
seniors their own room and we let them
stay up all night
and i do the room checks to make sure
everyone's asleep and i go into the
senior room
and all of his friends are like gathered
around him and he's still
freaking the [ __ ] out right
like every teacher come here pray for
him and he's like
they won't stop man they're everywhere
they're everywhere what the [ __ ]
freaking out so he's like every teacher
will you go in the bathroom with me i
have to pee
but i can't be alone and i was like okay
i went in the bathroom with this guy
he's like watch me
watch me puke all right
this guy was scared to [ __ ] death
he's
seeing [ __ ] literally seeing [ __ ] i'm
i'm seeing this happen before me too and
i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do and i
think about the most
biblical youth group thing i can right
hey guys
let's get in a circle and hold hands
right yeah
and let's pray for it right and
whatever popcorn prayer they do that
[ __ ] and i'm like
and i have it in my head i'm like hey
you know what
maybe you say in the name of jesus
i rebuke you statement maybe you should
say that and then he's like all right
he goes in the name of jesus i rebuke
you said
you [ __ ] started freaking the [ __ ]
out
like screaming screaming and running
into the walls
and [ __ ] punching himself in the face
and scratching his
face off and so i grabbed his [ __ ]
arms
right and this kid started having
[ __ ] superhuman strength and like
curling me [ __ ] and dude i'm trying to
keep his arm down
i'm telling all the other kids grab his
arms grab his arms and we're wrestling
this kid and he's like
ah there's a i can't open my eyes
he won't open his eyes right it's a face
it's a
face and i'm like oh my god i'm freaking
the [ __ ] out
and then slowly one by one other past
our teachers came in because they
thought we were wrestling and fighting
this yeah
right yeah come on and they saw that we
were just
yeah praying for him and he was just
like yeah
and so all the other teachers came down
to try to pray for him and then like i
heard one story one of the other seniors
because he's a [ __ ] weirdo oppa he
goes into the seventh grade girls room
and then he opens the door and they're
like what's going on up there
right that's who's fighting and he goes
so and so is demon possessed pray for
him and closes the door on it
it just freaks out all these [ __ ]
seventh grade girls
what the [ __ ] would he do i didn't even
so apparently these little
girls are [ __ ] funny did not sleep
all night yeah how the [ __ ] would they
and they just hear us boom wrestling
upstairs
right and like just [ __ ] trying to
pray for this kid
i don't know if you know anything about
tongues oh yes pranking tongues and [ __ ]
yeah i went off
i just went off on tongues yeah and i
don't know how it comes about it just
[ __ ]
yeah it just came out and
until the [ __ ] pastors finally showed
up and then he just kind of like
chilled out right and then they were
with him for
like 10 minutes or whatever and it came
out like he's fine
and then he was okay he was [ __ ] okay
and it's like oh
sorry guys and then they went to bed the
next morning
he was like thank you edward hyung like
thank you
like for taking care of me like you were
there for me right and so this guy's
half white half korean
right and he goes you know when you were
praying in tongue
i understood everything you said what
the [ __ ] so what
and he goes because he's halfway half
korean his mom's korean doesn't speak
a lick of [ __ ] english yeah she
speaks to him in korean
and he can't speak korean but he
understands it he speaks back to her in
english
yeah he said it's like that i don't i
can't speak it
but i knew what you were saying i was
like what the
[ __ ] what did he say you were saying i
don't know like i said
i can't speak it like but i knew what
you were saying yeah i said
and then i was just like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] like this
demonic [ __ ] is real right
all right fast forward 10 years later
hanging out with some
tongsens they're like oh yeah he smoked
a huge blind he was blasted
oh my god
dude he was wrecked dude
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] dude this [ __ ] dude
so he essentially was going through what
i was going through yes
he thought he was gonna die well i
thought i was gonna [ __ ] die
get the [ __ ] out of here
dude your whole life you're like dude i
had this moment where i spoke tongue and
then like
no this was blasted he's like guys you
know
that's [ __ ] funny dude he was
essentially going what i was going
through
but i had you there to tell me like hey
nobody died from this
just relax oh yeah if if to
today me there was there too and he told
me i'm super high you know i would have
been like yeah relax
yeah are you i'm praying for him against
the forces of satan
yeah i want to start socking him in the
face like hey calm the [ __ ] down dude
that's hilarious dude oh my goodness
that's so [ __ ] funny man
like i can't even cause i know now i
know what that feels like the whole
thing where i feel like my body is it's
a literal outer where i'm body
experience
myself going dude you're dead do you
think do you think that
leader was probably high too a hundred
percent dude
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] dude he had to be
he's just like he goes i'm high and he's
high but i'm not gonna let anybody know
this
but all those retreats still everybody
was doing crazy [ __ ] man
it was like you're away from home but
like
i don't know somebody was hooking up
dude man i because i'm recently on
facebook again
uh only because i'm on marketplace just
to buy things and sell things like
camera care and stuff
uh i get to see a lot of people that i
haven't seen in a very long time
and there's one specific girl that i
remember uh
because well first of all i did
something kind of [ __ ] up to her where
uh
it was like you know when we have these
these um
these lockdowns where you're at church
and you can spend the night at church
yeah a bunch of leaders you guys pray
together and everything else
well every now and then somebody would
tell a scary story right and so she got
freaked out and she goes hey like can
you walk me to the bathroom
and then just wait outside and then just
wait for me there until i'm done
right please i was like okay cool so she
goes to the bathroom are you in there
she goes yeah and i shut off the lights
right and i turn it back on i keep
flickering the lights on and i bought it
off
[ __ ] hated my guts dude she [ __ ]
hit here's the worst part right
so she gets out and she's pissed
she tries to chase me down i have a
because i went to go while she was doing
that
i went to go um after i shut it off i
just went inside my own the men's
bathroom just to wash my hair
and then hear her screaming i'm cracking
the [ __ ] up i'm an [ __ ]
i come back out she's fuming mad right
she tries chasing me down instinctually
what i do i take my towel and i whip it
at her
and i [ __ ] whip her in the eyeball
i'll not talk the worst thing i could
ever do and she's sitting there
screaming in the bath that comes out i
hit her in the eyeball she's like
now i'm mortified i'm like this is it
was supposed to be a simple prank and it
just got [ __ ] out of hand well
this i and long story short about this
girl right and i see her with this photo
and
it's always a weird experience when i
see somebody in the future who i know is
[ __ ] crazy
yeah and they have a family
right because i know who they are prior
to this family
and i'm thinking like yo how does she
dupe this guy into marrying her because
she's [ __ ]
because she's [ __ ] nuts let me
explain to you the story right so she
used to go out with this other dude at a
different church right in sacramento
there's a few churches there's sk
there's sk pc sacramento korean
presbyterian church
there's i think there's one called zion
of course there's
you know there's skbc the baptist church
right and there was also
one called uh i think it's called arc or
something like that
but that's the one i used to go to
intermittently she was dating somebody
else from another church
he came to our church later on his
family moved churches to ours they
started dating right
this guy i [ __ ] hated he was like a
little racist [ __ ] he always said some
racist [ __ ] about vietnamese people
black people i [ __ ] hated this dude
but and of course he would go to [ __ ]
church available
but one day he comes to church and he
has
uh s likes gashes all over his face his
neck and all this other stuff
and we're like bro what the [ __ ]
happened to you
and he tells us that this girl he broke
up with her the night before
and she wouldn't accept the breakup like
i didn't know that you could do that
you know like hey we're broken up i
don't think so you know
and then she's like we're not broken up
because i know you you we're done
and so he breaks up with her goes to his
house right or he hangs out with a bunch
of friends and at night he comes back to
his house
well he comes back to his house his
windows open
she snuck into his room and she was
waiting with him with a fort with a
[ __ ] knife
nice and she's like we're not breaking
up you're not [ __ ] leaving me and she
starts
coming at him with a knife and starts
trying to slash him oh my god
right so that night before he got caught
up
he like [ __ ] shoved her to the wall
he told me he shoved her and he ran out
of his house
and he shoved her pretty [ __ ] hard so
she was like down she started crying on
the floor or whatever
and then came back and then she like was
crying and then he kind of took the
knife away from her and she was
bawling her eyes out and she just left
but she [ __ ]
tried to stab this dude like with the
knife like cutting him with this [ __ ]
knife i don't know what type of knife it
was but she was coming at him with the
point where he had gashes all over his
body
and then i see this picture of her
married to a guy with a kid
i completely forgot that's where the
story started
i'm like utterly shocked
fast forward [ __ ] 15 years and i'm
like who the [ __ ] marry this girl oh
wow and i now i want to know the pieces
it's like
then i start thinking to myself like yo
does he know that she's a [ __ ]
psychopath
that she tried to [ __ ] kill somebody
because they broke up with her
you know and i see she has a kid and
she's with a man facebook is weird man
it takes me into this weird space
i mean at the same time it could also be
a little predictive
like you see the people who fall into
the um
mlm schemes they sell that [ __ ] on face
but they're always the same people like
single
christian women who are looking for
who are hoping to be somebody's harmony
yeah
those are the types all the time yeah
you know what's so interesting too i
keep like
listen there's i say like i want to say
a majority of christian people that i
meet they're really really sweet people
but the crazies are [ __ ] crazy man oh
yeah
yeah it's got to be real or else why do
i exist
right yeah that's why i went too [ __ ]
it's gotta be real
like the lady who who took my dog
hostage
she was a she was a christian lady right
and listen like i said
in her hearts of heart she thought she
was doing something right
but she's like so this past christmas
right after that whole thing she found
out i did a video on it i didn't say her
name yeah do any of that type of stuff
because i want to keep the enemy and
like i want her to be anonymous
but her somebody saw that video like her
daughter had sent it to us like hey did
this happen or whatever so she you know
messes marielle and called her
apologizing saying like hey i didn't
mean to come off that way or whatever
i was like yeah but you literally said
you weren't going to give our dog back
unless we went to you with the pound and
got her chip and if not i can't have her
back
which by the way like they every vet
told me to call the cops on her yeah
they're like
that's illegal you need to call the cops
that's what they said like they're
literally holding like your kid hostage
like
she cannot do that right and so i was
like oh you're right i didn't even think
about it like that i just wanted my dog
back
but this past christmas she messaged
meryl merry christmas
[ __ ] we don't want to hear from you
yeah [ __ ] are you talking about she's
like
we're friends yeah this entitlement
remember me i saved your dog
no no you kept her hostage and you made
me feel like a piece of [ __ ]
because our dog ran away like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know i mean
it's it's one of those things too like
if you still go to church today like
you find out like half these
[ __ ] believe in like conspiracy
theories and [ __ ] too
yeah it's like man how do you believe in
god and this crazy [ __ ] at the same time
yeah well that's what facebook too
is the worst for old people oh yeah it's
their version of twitter
yeah do it dude it's it's there's a
whole subreddit i like going to it's
called
insane people facebook and old people
facebook
it was just like there's so much content
coming out of crazy old people
they have so much [ __ ] to say yeah and
they
seem to think that the world works this
way like around their bubble
dude like i it only reminded me and
these people aren't really my friends
like acquaintances that i know right
yeah somebody posted this mean about the
covet vaccine
and i'm like well let's read this right
and they were and they were
trying to say they were trying to make a
point about how stupid the vaccine is
and they go
imagine not getting sick from something
and then getting a vaccine and getting
sick from it
and he wrote ella well people are so
dumb and i'm like
this is the dumbest thing i've ever read
in my life and there are people who
thumbs up and like that comment
and i just i was baffled right and then
somebody
did our job and they wrote for them
they're like like hey dumbass they're
like
do you i was like i was like don't
aren't you a [ __ ] personal trainer do
you work out because you have a heart
attack now or do you do it to prevent it
right and the guy was like you're so
you're you're a [ __ ] sheep he's like
you didn't even answer the question
yeah like do you work out because it's
preventative so you don't get sick in
the future so you stay healthy
right yeah dude like why do you take
vitamins
facebook breeds those kind of conflicts
yeah
that's the problem with facebook is
because they don't actually offer
anything to society like i stay on
facebook because
i'm we you and i we're damn near on the
cusp of gen x
yeah all of our friends have kids yeah
they have families and that's how we
connect and stay connected yeah you know
like instagram for us is more or less
just expressing
random [ __ ] yeah you know and then
like i try to stay connected on facebook
but these
people are [ __ ] crazy yeah they love
fighting and arguing all the time and
then when someone when they report to
signaling
and woke theology and then on the other
side crazy anti-science
and [ __ ] christian prophecies
and it's crazy too because they're
having arguments with people that they
that are supposedly their friends when
they could meet up and just talk about
it
but they'll argue on facebook it's like
bro don't they live right around the
corner for me just call them bro
yeah yeah culver beer because it's
easier just to make point for point and
make it a spectacle
yeah you know it's such an odd thing
like facebook is pretty bad man i had no
idea it offers
it contributes nothing to our souls into
our to humanity
and to society i'm constantly on the
cusp of why am i still on here
yeah but it's just there's a lot of
friends yeah
i don't post much twitter is the worst
dude he really it's worse than twitter's
ten times worse than facebook man why so
just because there's
like i uh did i tell you i almost got
cancelled
a little i saw what was happening yeah
and so like i
i gave a little korean language lesson
yeah it was
it was so [ __ ] ridiculous because
people were trying to cancel me on
twitter
over a sketch that where i said a korean
word right right and obviously the joke
is that it sounds a lot like the n-word
and the joke the the joke that we were
making is how people don't understand
that there's
different languages it means it means
different things it happens a lot
it's based off of something that
happened with my best friend so i was at
um
the beauty supply store with my mom and
she said niga
and he was like what's your mom saying
as a joke and we were cracking up
[ __ ] laughing right
and i was like oh that would be a funny
little vine for batch right and so like
batch did this
exactly this this vine about i'm coming
in
and i goes oh hi i was like that means
you sit over here right and he was like
what'd you say i said
he goes excuse me and he goes i was like
oh he's like i'm telling his cream goes
oh i get it i was like
it's like [ __ ] hit your ass down like
you sit your ass down
right so i'm not saying the n word
that's the joke
millions of people understand every
korean american growing up like
knew that bottom line joke we're not
going to say out loud
and like but vine and with like king
batch and all that that
was like you guys were doing a series of
[ __ ] rush hour four
nights kids and [ __ ] exactly yeah and it
was an extension of that
here's the [ __ ] worst part and this
is where i
was like it's an example of these young
kids trying to virtue signal so [ __ ]
hard
so after i wrote my defense people
started going back and started bashing
this person right
and that person wrote the end of he goes
oh i actually don't even really care
when the what they wrote was like can
you believe that this stuff on vine is
acceptable it makes me
literally stick to my stuff makes me
sick to my stomach and at the end of it
because
this person started getting heat they're
like i don't even care that much
this is what i'm talking about this is
an example of why
virtue signaling is trash i hope this
generation understands
why doing that makes you look like a
[ __ ] dumbass you do not
care about society you do not care about
what's happening to people
you only care about how you look to
other people right that's why i don't
give a
[ __ ] about your activism because of
people like that
and you know people are like oh don't
let the one bad seed no that's more than
one bad seed a majority of you people
are like that
you speak up only because it makes you
look good not because you're trying to
make a difference
it's the only place they have a voice
too yeah right where they have a
chance of getting hundreds if not
thousands of retweets
right or hundreds and thousands of likes
depending on how well
you do your hashtags yeah or some [ __ ]
especially if it requires a hashtag
because like what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah like what the funny thing is too
it's like i've been doing this [ __ ] for
years
even before it was cool you know this
podcast is brought to you by
better help if you haven't focused on
your mental health this year
now is the time to start listen we all
been cooped up tense and honestly
we know the importance of our mental
health so let's stop pushing our
thoughts
emotions and feelings aside and get the
help we need better help will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time
while setting up weekly video phone
sessions it's super convenient
and more importantly it allows you to be
comfortable and safe in your own
environment
listen i've used better health and it
was honestly amazing and the experience
till this day has been super beneficial
for me i still talk to my counselor till
this day
and you have nothing to lose so give it
a try so remember this podcast is
sponsored by better health
and genius brain listeners get 10 off
their first month
at betterhelp.com genius
and i was compelled to say something at
all and i just kind of took the heat i'm
not
i'm not trying to put myself on a
crucifix or anything else like that
but if you really did care where the
[ __ ] were you before
right you had years to do this i've been
doing this damn near for like 12 years
now in my stand-up comedy my jokes my
videos
and at the end of the day it was like oh
i've always felt these feelings no you
didn't
you you absolutely did not somebody told
you you're supposed to feel this
exactly you didn't feel that way and
that's also okay
it's like why else would you feel this
way unless someone told you
what you don't know and you they made
you feel shitty and now you
[ __ ] project that [ __ ] pass it on to
someone don't you know
it's bad like now you're doing it to me
yeah you know
it's just really weird man that whole
situation was like i can't believe
somebody tried to cancel me
over something that's not even cancel
worthy like this is the dumbest [ __ ]
thing your vacation came at the perfect
time then yeah
dude the vacation let me tell you what
happened prior to vacation dude yeah
i i could i already knew that i was out
to lunch i told you this before i did a
whole podcast with like nick and pat
i didn't record any of the audio record
the video
you already know i'm out to [ __ ]
lunch dude
so that the the day before that [ __ ]
hell
it's a very weird situation so i'm
driving out of the the old office right
i still have stuff there i have still
have it for another month
and so i'm driving out and i'm peeking
out of of the the parking lot you know
picking my car out
and you see this homeless lady with the
cart she looks [ __ ] deranged right
sunburned [ __ ] beanie everything it's
like 80 degrees outside
she looks and i just hear screaming at
me like [ __ ] irritated i think it's
because i'm
picking my car out she goes around it
and [ __ ] kicks my truck oh
[ __ ] boom kicks it i'm like what the
[ __ ]
right and i'm like all right cool
whatever i'm in my car i do a u-turn
i turn around and i see this lady and
you know what she does to me she goes
she goes she gives me the [ __ ] you and
she
jacks off her imaginary dick and throws
it on my face
she goes me and she does the [ __ ]
b-boy move where she jacks off her dick
and throws it on my face
i'm like yo what the [ __ ] is happening
right now right
and i go back i look in my car there's
no damage and the only thing i can think
of is this was
okay how do i win in this situation yeah
one
am i yelling at a lady two am i yelling
at a homeless person yeah three do i
beat a homeless person's ass right
where do i win i just have to take it
this lady is still jacking off with her
dick and throwing it in my face
[Laughter]
dude the worst and you know what
happened to me the day before that this
is where i knew i needed this vacation
yeah this is why i was just out
i'm [ __ ] done day before right
so this person i'm trying to get into
their lane and this person stops midway
slows down i'm assuming they're allowing
me to to come in
but it turns out that they were just on
their phone and they didn't know and
they were slowing down
and so i was like oh cool i'll just go
in and i went in this person wasn't
paying attention
uh and i and looks up and he slams his
brakes because he didn't see me because
he was texting on his phone
and i just and i just give him a wave
saying thank you for letting me and i
was like thanks like that
person speeds up goes next to my car
goes tells me to roll down my window
he goes [ __ ] you i'm gonna say the word
they call me call me a [ __ ] he goes
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and i'm like yo what the
f i don't make what why is he cursing at
me right like
he said thank you right and i'm like
what's up he goes give me the [ __ ]
middle finger you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i was like i gave you a
thank you and i go bro i was saying
thank you for letting me in he goes
oh all right dead my bad he just burned
[ __ ] jets off because he's
embarrassed he goes oh [ __ ]
and he just jets off i'm like dog need a
[ __ ] vacation
[ __ ] la man like out of everything that
could happen i literally waved him hey
thanks for letting me in
and he saw a middle finger dude i've had
one of those nights too in k-town
it was just a long night working all
night i'm coming home
and i guess i was swerving i i i wasn't
drinking or nothing i was just [ __ ]
tired
and i'm just minding my business and at
a red light
this black s-class pulls up
and the window rolls down and it's this
korean dude but he looks like a
[ __ ] gangster he's tatted up all
across he's wearing a basketball jersey
he goes hey i rolled down my window i'm
like
yeah you know you're driving like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and i said oh i'm sorry i'm just really
tired
and then his girlfriend in the scene
went oh
and then he went all right then all
right
babe you're such a dick
look at him he's sad he's gonna [ __ ]
yell at him
babe are you out of your [ __ ] mind
hilarious dude some people just kind of
[ __ ]
is that that's that l.a road rage too
though man
it's like on like it's it's like no
other
i can even think of the aggressiveness
and the
[ __ ] like that offensive type driving
where they're just gonna get you back
for some [ __ ] you didn't even know you
did
yeah yeah like i i i didn't have road
rage until i came to the city
yeah yeah i didn't know what it was i
came here i
i used to sit in traffic for two hours
in in washington
from seattle to tacoma every weekend
marielle saw
my road rage for the first time and she
was so disappointed
she was so upset at me and this is like
our first
task this is like us being together like
officially for two months and we were
going to
either we were going back from the
museum and we had a date
and i had my mom was on the phone right
and i was talking to her
in the car with neriel in the car as
well and then
i'm driving and there's this car it's a
it's a bentley i think i can't remember
i think it was a bentley it's a really
expensive car and i'm driving
and this guy [ __ ] almost pushes me
off the road
right and so like literally almost fears
me off and kills me i'm like oh
[ __ ] right because the guy wasn't paying
attention and you know he's driving like
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm not i'm
not by the way i'm not sure if i told
this part of so i'm not the only one
pissed at him because he was like
[ __ ] like me like a nut bag and
everybody was honking i was like man
[ __ ] you i just gave him the finger like
this he sees it through my window
this time i really did give the finger
yeah [ __ ] you right because the guy
almost kills me
i drive by and at this point i was
already having a terrible week there's a
few other stuff that happened this week
this is actually the same week uh no
it's not it's a different week but i'm
driving
and then um he comes down tells me to
roll down my window
right you go he's doing this i don't
know what everybody [ __ ] does that
and you're like they want to say
something they want to say some [ __ ] so
he's telling me to roll down the window
and this is mario's in the in the seat
next to me and i'm just like
what what the [ __ ] i roll down the
window he goes roll down the [ __ ]
window
right and he just starts like going off
on me
and i'm like what i couldn't process
what was going on it's like normalcy
bias
right you don't know what's going on and
i think he kind of thought because he's
looking at
my little dweeb or whatever and then i
turned it i'm like
the [ __ ] you say to me you [ __ ] made
[ __ ] and i start going off right
right and the dude is like shocked like
yo what the [ __ ] and i
literally i said slow the [ __ ] down pull
over so i can [ __ ] you up
so i slam my [ __ ] brakes and i get
behind him right and i'm screaming i'm
like pull the [ __ ] over
right and it's not we're not going that
fast on the freeway it's kind of
trafficking
and then mariel is just like what the
[ __ ] is going on
and the dude is trying to dodge me so
i'm chasing after my rollover
[ __ ] i'm chasing after him and i roll up
next to him because you know cards are
kind of getting in the way i roll
his the window's still down i was like
let's [ __ ] go hurry the [ __ ]
pull the [ __ ] over and i'm waiting him
for him to come over and this guy
finally ditches me by cutting off into
another freeway and he leaves
and then mario looks at me like just
disappointed
maybe she was a little scared because
she hasn't seen some [ __ ] like that
before but this is pretty typical
right i'm [ __ ] fuming and i forgot i
was talking to my mom on the phone
and then my mom just goes
oh [ __ ]
calm as [ __ ] just disappointed in me
just
lecturing me and i was i fell on the
bluetooth
bluetooth speaker dude on your first few
days
but exactly and then my mom starts
lecturing me about my behavior and how i
have a terrible temper she goes remember
when you were younger
you used to get in fights all the time i
thought you were better than this like i
thought you don't get the fights anymore
like
she started going to this whole like
guilt trip of all the [ __ ] that i had to
put her through
you know because of like my violent
behaviors and getting kicked out of
school
and i just sat there and the mario
looked at me and that was actually the
first time mary looked me she wanted to
break up with me
yeah it was early on in a relationship
she goes do i want to be with somebody
who behaves like this
it's like um you're a
young speaker right now she didn't even
know mario was next year remember your
time you stabbed that guy in the face
stop stop stop stop stop stop but muriel
would had had a moment where she thought
she was gonna break up with me because
she was disappointed in how i handled
that situation
but i used to have a really short temper
but let me let me
let me be on your side first yeah
haven't you noticed that every time
you you reciprocated they always [ __ ]
back down
yeah anyone that has real not real let
me just say road rage
like in la when you reciprocate they're
just
they don't think you're going to say
anything back yeah
every time i run into that and man if
you're in la you understand it happens
all the [ __ ] time
some [ __ ] wants you to roll down
your window and i roll it down
and i just and i do the hulk hogan yeah
and i start smiling yeah and i start
like
and i start patronizing them either that
or i'm just like
yeah let me have it yeah and then they
just kind of run out of things
yeah they don't have anything else to do
yeah what were you gonna do
they weren't gonna do nothing and in
that case too he was surprised i was
literally telling him to pull over on
the freeway so we could duke it out it's
like let's [ __ ] go
that's that's short-sightedness where'd
you think this was gonna go
this [ __ ] you know like is in
l.a there is a
[ __ ] high probability of all these
events constantly happening
you don't know who the [ __ ] you're going
to run into dude let me tell you this
one time though where i
i i didn't gamble well so there's this
card that [ __ ]
cut me off and almost veered me off too
and i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
right i have my window down already
right this car hits its brakes on the
freeway slows down
it's just a bunch of cholos in the clock
and you're
[ __ ] tatted up on the face and
everything like they're like what's up
fool
i was like my bad bro i just wanted to
apologize
oh yes today korea yeah today america
bye-bye i am so sorry
you know jesus christ
no but these dudes were like literally
hanging out the [ __ ] like what's up
what's up and i'm like yo i just said my
bad y'all and they were still [ __ ]
flashing gang signs at me
until they [ __ ] left and i was like
damn i could have died you don't wanna
know that
i don't want none of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
five dudes like packed into a [ __ ]
like honda accord i'm like
let me tell you something anybody that's
bold enough to threaten somebody in a
beater like that they don't give a [ __ ]
about my life
but they don't care yeah that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] scary dude
yeah and that was the only time for me
was this the k-town thug
that's what i was like i'm sorry i'm so
sorry
just let me empathize with your
girlfriend i would have just pulled
something quick out of the car and said
i go to church with your mom
it's like really young
everybody's mom goes for young men yeah
you go to young knox it's like yeah your
mom talks about you a lot
hey don't tell her i was here
oh [ __ ] that was already an hour whoa
well
we were supposed
[Laughter]
all right we'll talk about it again yeah
we'll talk about it next time
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast i hope you
enjoyed this podcast very much
i uh you could find ed at ed parkvp also
as a podcast
yep uh bible study at momos i also have
a keto page that i don't give a [ __ ]
about oh okay
okay yeah check out his keto page if you
guys are interested in trying uh keto
uh and genius brains every thursdays and
sundays and we will see you all next
time
peace bye